[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce set
8 les invités une émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département est aujourd'hui mercredi
29 mars parole à hervé le goff militants
yvelinois du npa le nouveau parti
anticapitaliste nous évoquerons avec lui
la campagne présidentielle de son parti
certaines propositions de son candidat
philippe poutou et la façon de faire
campagne dans un département classé à
droite comme les yvelines parole aussi
dans cette émission à denis verdier
agneaux le directeur du développement
culturel du château de versailles il
nous présentera les journées européennes
est des métiers d'art prévue bientôt au
château cette année le public était
invité à rencontrer ceux qui font vivre
le théâtre de la reine régisseur
machinistes ou encore peintre en décor
monde débutent donc cette émission avec
vous et hervé le goff bonsoir bonsoir
hervé le goff vous êtes donc
informaticien à la retraite militants du
npa je le disais dans les yvelines npa
pour le nouveau parti anticapitaliste
votre candidat avoué connu c'est
philippe poutou et il a réussi
finalement à réunir les 500 parrainages
nécessaires 573 précisément ça s'est
joué dans les derniers jours pour lui on
le sait est ce que vous avez eu peur que
votre candidat ne soient pas représentés
ou alors vous y avez toujours cru vous
le saviez mais on a eu très peur
effectivement de ne pas réunir les 500
parrainages ça a été une épreuve
difficile
on a travaillé sur le terrain depuis
plusieurs mois et les dernières semaines
ont été vraiment très dure jusqu'au
dernier
au dernier carat on n'était pas sûr de
les réunir alors notamment dans notre
secteur de nous travaillons sur le
secteur de l'eure et loir les yvelines
dont on a fait un petit peu une croix
dessus
oui c'est ce que j'allais vous dire
parce que j'ai fouillé sur le site du
conseil constitutionnel n 0 parrainage
en provenance des yvelines est-ce que
c'est à dire que vous n'avez pas essayé
de chercher dans les yvelines ou alors
que personne n'a voulu n'a souhaité vous
donnez votre parrainage dans les
yvelines - sait par expérience en fait
on sait que
dans les yvelines les votes pour le npa
est ridicule 1 on est à 0 8%
ensuite on sait que les les parrainages
sont allés aux trois quarts pour fillon
pour françois fillon dès le début donc
on a même généré mélenchon en a eu que
deux dans le département
oui oui oui donc c'est une situation qui
aurait été impossible on aurait eu pas
réussi à prendre des parrainages
donc on a choisi un département qui est
plutôt rurale avec des petites communes
où les mères sont effectivement plus
près de ddd gens dans l'eure-et-loir
dans les yvelines un département vous
l'avez dit forcément est difficile pour
votre combat pour votre parti politique
vous avez combien de militants
d'ailleurs ce que vous avez un chiffre
précis vous connaissez les forces je
vous donnerai pas de chiffres précis
nous sommes
une trentaine à peu près dont tout le
monde ne se réunit pas tout le temps
donc j'ai pas j'ai pas les chiffres
exacts et vos bassins d'activité c'est
le mantois
c'est aussi peut-être la verrière trappe
alors nos bassins d'activité sont les
bassins d'activités industrielles 1 donc
on assure la région de renault
j'ai su à poissy aussi ça me voilà là où
il ya des usines là où il ya des usines
et où bon sur trappe aussi où on fait
effectivement plusieurs diffusions à ce
problème à ce propos comment vous faites
campagne vous dans les yvelines pour
pour philippe poutou est ce que vous
faites du tractage sur les marchés comme
font les autres partis devant les gares
ou alors vous allez devant les usines
plutôt à la sortie des usines
alors on fait principalement bon il ya
une campagne d'affichage qui va être
mené donc va afficher on va essayer d'
afficher partout avec nos moyens qui
sont pas énormes
et puis effectivement on va cibler plus
tôt en tractage les bassins d'emploi on
va on va cibler renault va cibler poissy
la centrale de porcheville les gars on
va effectivement faire on va faire comme
les autres on dit mais bon avec vos
moyens avec nos moyens
1 c'est difficile on y croit on
s'accroche toujours quand on est
militant comme vous alors on se dit
finalement on n'a pas de moyens on sait
que forcément ça va être difficile de
passer le premier tour même très très
compliqué on va être réaliste est-ce qu
on est toujours malgré tout encouragé
habilité est ce qu on a toujours cette
envie cette gnac nécessaire du militant
bien sûr qu'on a bien sûr qu'on a envie
dont on a envie d'abattre le capitalisme
on a envie de plus de justice dans ce
monde
d'autant plus qu'on est fiers quand même
de notre candidat qui est qui est un
candidat ouvriers qui n'a rien à voir
avec les candidats que les autres
candidats qui se présentent
il est près des problèmes de la
population donc on est fier de ce
candidat
on peut se dire effectivement se
présenter aux présidentielles on sait
bien qu'on ne passera pas le premier
tour
l'objectif c'est le fera entendre votre
voix le plus largement voilà exactement
les idées des travailleurs des plus
précaires exactement le c'est
l'opportunité effectivement disposé ont
là que tous les cinq ans de disposer
d'un porte-voix savait que notre notre
emblème c'est le porte-voix disposer
d'un porte voix pour exprimer la colère
des travailleurs pour exprimer les
grandes lignes d'un programme d'urgence
qu'ils ressentent comme indispensable
justement on va parler peut-être un peu
rapidement de ce programme notamment
d'un point de vue économique dont vous
le disiez vous l'avez dit vous-même
abattre le capitalisme et ça ça passe
par exemple par pour lutter contre le
chômage les 32 heures pour tous un smic
à 1700 euros ou encore l'interdiction
des licenciements est ce que vous
estimez que dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
avec les données d'aujourd'hui tout ça
c'est applicable
ou alors c'est surtout comme vous le
disiez porter quelques idées comme ça
pour que ça émergent dans le débat
public
bien sûr que cette applicable mais
celles applicables ce n'est pas
applicable dans un régime présidentiel
tel qu'on connaît actuellement la
volonté elle doit venir de la base elle
doit venir des travailleurs
donc c'est pas effectivement en amenant
un homme providentiel comme président
qui décidera d'interdire les
licenciements
c'est aux travailleurs de prendre leur
destin en mains avec des mouvements
sociaux par exemple avec des mouvements
sociaux une révolte et où est-ce qu'on
est encore dans cette mythe là dans ce
mythe l'a souvent souvent montré du
doigt pointé du doigt par parra par nos
ennemis politiques de la révolution
prolétarienne ça se sera pas c'est pas
une révolution comme en 1917 c'est pas à
les pendre tous les
les méchants capitalistes c'est les
virer tout simplement et les virer c'est
par des mouvements sociaux effectivement
c'est des greffes cdc une conjonction de
toutes les usines qui se mettent en
grève c'est c'est la volonté des
travailleurs
un peu comme en 1900 finalement dans les
années 1930 avec les congés payés et ce
qui s'est passé ensuite voilà exactement
comme un petit question contre on quand
on lit votre programme quand on écoute
les discours on se demande pourquoi il
n'y a pas une candidature commune avec
lutte ouvrière et nathalie arthaud
vous semblez porter que tout de même les
mêmes combats alors pourquoi ne pas être
ensemble pour peser plus justement
notamment en termes de voix bien sûr
nathalie arthaud c'est bon c'est une
camarade 1 et trotskistes sont deux
partis trotskistes on a quelques
différences de vues sur la façon de
mener donné la future révolution on est
on a des propositions qui sont un peu
différentes des leurs notamment sur les
participations aux combats sur les
grands projets inutiles sur l'écologie
sur le nucléaire
bon ce qui fait que ça n'a pas pu
aboutir
donc vous vous le disiez vous même tout
à l'heure ça va être compliqué pour vous
et ses manières question c'est d'être
compliqué pour vous de passer le premier
tour
ça veut dire qu'au second tour vous vous
associez dre ou alors vous serez tout
sauf marine le pen c'est un peu alors
non notre notre position pour l'instant
c'est de
de demander enfin de s'abstenir
aujourd'hui tous ceux qui passeront le
second tour on les a vus on les a vus au
pouvoir on a vu ce que ça a donné
macron il était au gouvernement les
socialistes sont allés au gouvernement
aussi donc on laisse le choix aux gens
c'est de battre après contre marine le
pen si c'est elle qui arrivent au
pouvoir mais on se battra aussi contre
l'autre l'autre candidat merci à hervé
le goff d'être venu en plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes membre du npa
dans les yvelines merci à vous et puis
bonne compagne campagne excusez moi sans
transition on prend à présent la
direction de versailles près de 200
métiers et 80 spécialités à découvrir
c'est ce que propose la 11e les 11e
journée européenne des métiers d'art
durant trois jours des professionnels
d'exception vont partager leur savoir
faire c'est notamment le cas de ceux du
château de versailles qui participent à
l'événement écoutez denis verdier manioc
le directeur du développement culturel
du château de versailles il était au
micro de michael et demi d'euros c'est
une manière pour nous de montrer ses
savoir-faire c'est technicité
particulière qui sont développées par
des artisans dont les métiers d'art
qu'il s'agisse de fontainier de
jardiniers de doreur de ferronniers
tapissier contribuent très largement à
une meilleure compréhension pour nos
visiteurs de la manière dans ce lieu est
entretenu maintenu voire restaurer quand
c'est nécessaire voire aller parfois
jusqu'à des recréations quand les états
ont disparu avec les transformations
conte puis apportée par exemple louis
philippe lors de la création du musée
d'histoire de france
pourquoi verser y participent à ces
journées européennes alors versailles
participent à ces journées parce que
pour nous c'est très important de
montrer à nos publics aux visiteurs du
lieu que ce lieu est vivant avec ses
pratiques de métier également et qui lui
permet de mieux appréhender à ce
visiteur à ce public
comment sont réalisés ces activités
d'entretien de maintenance que
j'évoquais à l'instant
et quelle est la programmation cette
année à versailles alors la
programmation elle vient de s'achever
avec une grande exposition sur les fêtes
et divertissement dont le cette semaine
et ces journées des métiers d'art
constituent un peu phénomène de
couronnement de l'activité parce que
dans cette exposition
nombre de ces métiers étaient présentés
et à l'instar de ce qu'on va faire ce
week-end au petit théâtre de marie
antoinette le visiteur aura pu prendre
mieux en compte le temps de travail
la difficulté de réalisation que
représentent ces décors et leur maintien
en l'état une fois qu'ils ont été
restaurés puisque ce petit théâtre a été
restaurée et il y a quelques années avec
le groupe lvmh
combien de personnes participent à
chaque édition de ces journées
européennes
alors on peut considérer qu'on arrive
proche de la période des vacances de
pâques et donc on va avoir beaucoup de
monde environ quelques dizaines de
milliers de personnes et c'est important
également pour les ouvriers de montrer
leur savoir faire
ah oui c'est très important pour eux
parce que c'est aussi un moyen de faire
savoir que ces savoir-faire ces
techniques qui sont ancestrales qui
remonte à plusieurs siècles maintenant
et qui sont développés bien sûr qu'ils
se sont affinés existe toujours sont
ceux de son sont maintenus on pourrait
même parler de développement puisque si
nous avons reçu d'aidé scolaire et les
publics jeunes 7 durant toute cette
semaine autour des métiers d'art c'est
aussi pour le faire savoir pour le faire
connaître et pour ces professionnels
c'est très important que de faire
connaître leur métier parce que c'est
vrai que ce n'est pas très répandu qui
est très commun versa il est lieu idéal
pour montrer son savoir faire
ah oui je pense lorsque un tel écran
s'il vous voulez qui regroupe autant de
techniques des savoir-faire et de métier
qu'il s'agisse des scènes de théâtre
l'opéra quand on a évoqué tout à l'heure
ou bien elles émettaient des jardins les
fontainiers les doreurs les jardiniers
d'art tous et tous ces métiers emploient
des techniques et des savoir faire qui
sont très particulier et qui trouvent là
leur expression la plus forte la pl plus
pour nos rangs les plus prégnants aux
yeux des visiteurs
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez que les
visiteurs retiennent de ces journées
j'aimerais qu'ils arrivent à retenir
justement que tout ce travail qui est
fait qu'on doit contribuer pour eux à
sauver et à maintenir ce patrimoine un
état avec une fréquentation qui est
importante avec un nombre de touristes
est toujours plus important en ile de
france
mais justement de faire savoir que la
france elle à ce degré d'excellence elle
a ses savoir faire et que ce sont des
métiers porteurs même pour l'avenir
parce que dans dans beaucoup de pays
justement il n'ya plus ses savoir faire
et c'est cette tradition des métiers
d'art
c'est la fin de ce set 8 les invités
prochain rendez vous demain jeudi soir
d'ici là retrouvez toutes nos séquences
en replay sur tv fil 78 points communs
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]
ans